and there seems to be no sign of
intelligent life anywhere
[Music]
hello this november toy story celebrates
its 25 year anniversary
the beloved animated adventure of toybox
allegiances was the first feature-length
film released by pixar
since 1995 the studio has gone on to win
16 academy awards
11 grammy awards and 10 golden globe
awards
but did you know that the first computer
animated movie studio was once owned by
star wars george lucas and
apple's steve jobs or that their first
initial breaks included star trek
and listerine you will join us as we
take a look back at the history of pixar
to infinity and beyond pixar started
16 years prior to releasing its first
feature length film when george lucas
recruited ed catmull
to lead lucasfilm's computer division
lucas had already worked with cat mall
whose company triple i had made the
x-wing fighter for star wars
simply called the graphics group at the
time what lucas wanted from this
arrangement was advancements in digital
film editing
and digital sound editing by 1982
graphics group completed the first
completely computer animated sequence
ever made for a feature film in star
trek ii the wrath of khan
the scene in question was a terraforming
sequence by the genesis device
where we witness a lifeless planet
suddenly transform in simulation
in 1984 the studio created its first
short film
called the adventures of andre and wally
b combining hand-painted textures with
flexible computer generated characters
this would be the first example of
character animation done by computers
the graphics group completed one more
feature film sequence for george lucas
the stained glass knight and young
sherlock holmes before steve jobs
purchased the company in 1986
one year after being ousted from
macintosh jobs bought the graphics group
for 5 million dollars and was the
largest shareholder in the company until
disney purchased pixar in 2006.
it was under jobs that pixar got its
name a combination of pixar a made-up
spanish word that sounded like to make
pictures
and radar for its futuristic learnings
but it also became the company that we
think of today because this is
also when the pixar lamp was first
introduced in the short
film luxo junior for the first five
years as an independent animation
company
pixar completed a number of shorts
including 1988's tin toy
and 1989's knick-knack which saw them
making large leaps and three-dimensional
movement
by 1991 pixar also made commercials for
trident and listerine
it was the commercial work that allowed
them to hire future film directors
andrew stanton
and pete docter it was also the
commercial work pipeline that showed the
studio could work with outside clients
and this led to pixar's first agreement
with disney signed in 1991
to make and distribute at least one
computer-generated animated movie
that first film of course would become
toy story
toy story was the perfect story for
pixar in 1995
because their technology made all
organic objects look plastic
which was ideal for a story concerning
the active life of toys when humans are
not around
the human rendering was so far behind
that originally the filmmakers hoped to
avoid showing humans all together
outside of limbs but early on faces for
the davis family and sid the evil
neighbor were deemed necessary for the
audience
though the human characters look off to
us now this only highlights the
monumental achievements that pixar has
done in advancing its own technology
through the years
stanton shaped the story as a buddy
movie and the writing team
including joss whedon alex sokolow and
joel cohen
added sarcasm that was atypical for
animated movies at the time
i'm just a couple of blocks away
if woody says it's all right then well
darn it it's good enough for me
i don't believe that man's ever been to
medical school we have to hold hands
oh yeah you guys think this is a big
joke pixar decided to avoid musical
numbers to differentiate itself from
disney proper
however production would be shut down to
retool woody's character to make him
more likeable
wait a minute you you don't think i
meant to knock buzz out the window do
you
potato that's mr potato head to you you
backstabbing murderer
stanton tasked the writers to make woody
and buzz engaging enough that if the
audience
were stuck in an elevator with them for
70 minutes it would still be
entertaining
the resulting film released in 1995 was
the highest grossing film of 1995 at 192
million
domestic and 360 million dollars
worldwide
far eclipsing jobs expectations that it
would break
even if it grows 75 million dollars
pixar's next film a bug's life allowed
the company to further its 3d character
mapping via a world without humans and
monsters inc
allowed them to animate many different
shapes and improve upon their human
forms
the directive at pixar was to create a
computer animated environment that had
not been done before and thus the team
went underwater
with finding nemo in 2003
are friends not food except stinking
dolphins
dolphins yeah they think they're so cute
oh look at me i'mma flip a little
dolphin let me flip i know something
in 2004 pixar's next landmark
achievement was the three-dimensional
human form in the incredibles
which then blew the door off the types
of stories pixar could tell
honey where's my super suit
what where is
[Music]
following that film's massive success in
2006 the animated studio was formally
sold to disney
for 7.4 billion dollars since the
incredibles pixar has created the
digital worlds of radiator springs and
cars
a french restaurant in ratatouille outer
space in wally
into the sky in ups balloon house to
scotland
in brave to the jurassic era in the good
dinosaur
inside a child's brain in inside out
into the afterlife in cocoa and a world
of mythical creatures in
onward over the past 25 years there have
been eight sequels to five
original franchises the incredibles 2
has been the biggest success at the box
office with 1.2 billion dollars earned
worldwide
and wally holds the record for the most
oscar nominations for a pixar movie at
6. all told pixar has earned 14.5
billion dollars at the worldwide box
office in addition to
all those golden statues because of the
covid pandemic their next original film
seoul will be released on disney plus
but there are four additional theatrical
pixar movies in the works
with releases in 2021 2022 and 2023
however only enrico casarosa's luca has
a title and plot as of this video's
publication date
set in a beautiful seaside town on the
italian riviera where all is idyllic
except for the sea monster that lives
offshore
luca will be pixar's 24th feature-length
film
so of all the pixar releases which is
your favorite
tell us in the comments below
[Music]
you